willkommen an der Militärakademie in
Wiener Neustadt mein Name ist Oberst
Markus Reisner ich bin der Leiter der
Entwicklungsabteilung und ich werde
Ihnen heute erklären die Gliederung
einer russischen bataillonskampfgruppe
jenes Elements das von der russischen
Streitkräften in der Ukraine zurzeit
sich im Einsatz befindet dazu schauen
wir uns jetzt im Detail die Gliederung
an
die Gliederung einer russischen
bataillonskampfgruppe kann man grob in
folgenden Elemente unterteilen in die
kampfteile hier befinden sich die
motorisierten und mechanisierten
infanteriekräfte sowie eine
kampfpanzerkompanie
zusätzlich in einem sehr hohen Maße
verfügbar sind die Teile der
kampfunterstützung dies umfasst
mitgeführte fliegerabwehrteile
raketenartillerie mittlerer Reichweite
raketenartillerie kurz erreichen und
rohrasie sowie zusätzliche weitere
Anteile zum Beispiel der pionierkräfte
zusätzlich haben wir Elemente der
Führung und Elemente der
drohnenaufklärung und der elektronischen
Kampfführung sowie einen
versorgungsanteil zu Versorgung dieser
Kräfte mit Betriebsmittel Waffen
Munition Verpflegung
sehen wir uns nun als Beispiel der
Kampfelemente eine Kampfbahn zur
Kompanie an
das hauptwaffensystem ist der d72 dieser
T-72 existiert in unterschiedlichen
Ausführungen eine Kompanie umfasst 10
Fahrzeuge gehen wir nun zurück und sehen
uns die kampfunterstützungsteile noch
einmal an
die kampfunterstützungsanteile haben wie
gesagt
rohrartillerie aber auch Raketenwerfer
sowie Fliegerabwehr aber spezielles
Element mit verheerender Wirkung den
sogenannten tos1 Buratino genannt das
russische Wort für Pinocchio
dieser tos1 ist dafür vorgesehen wenn
die kampfteile auf widerstandstreffen
halten diese und der tos1 verschießt auf
kurzentfernung von drei bis vier
Kilometern ein verheerendes
flächenwirksames Feuer durch der
moralische Raketen die mitführt das
räumt den Widerstand des Gegner zur
Seite und die Kampfpanzer und Infanterie
bzw mechanisierten Teile können weiter
angreifen
als weiteres Beispiel der
bataillonskampfgruppe sehen wir uns die
Führung an
diese Führung verfügt nicht nur über
bodengestützte aufklärungskräfte sondern
auch über mitgeführte drohnensysteme wie
hier in diesem Beispiel das
orlandiensystem das im Wesentlichen die
Aufklärung für die
kampfunterstützungsteile zur Verfügung
stellt
somit haben wir grob die Gliederung der
BTG dargestellt ich danke fürs zuhören
und alles Gute